in this video we will showcase to you
all the times godzilla was defeated in
battle
either by him being killed or trapped
retreating back into the ocean
critically injured
or being left in suspended animation you
know the usual stuff that are done to
defeat giant kaiju
oh so we all know godzilla as one of the
most iconic and most durable fictional
creatures to ever be created for the big
screen
and with his 30 plus films he usually
comes out on top but there are many
times that he would not be seen as the
victor
but rather the loser albeit after a huge
cause for the winning side sometimes
more than could be imagined
anyway let's dive into the many times
that he lost starting with
number one godzilla 1954 in his first
debut
the king of the monsters appeared for
the first time as a gigantic kaiju hell
bent on destroying japan godzilla was 50
meters tall
and is evolved from an ancient sea
animal that later became a terrestrial
creature
also he was the product of nuclear
testing in the pacific
in his first appearance he faced off
against us humans
and most notably the jsdf and there were
attempts to kill the monster with tanks
and jet fighters
but they all failed and afterwards
godzilla returns into the ocean
in the break between the attacks the
humans and the
sarizawa developed a new super weapon
called the oxygen destroyer
and this was used to kill the g-man so
in his first appearance he was actually
defeated by us humans
number two godzilla raids again 1955.
in the following year another member of
godzilla species awoken may be due to
constant hydrogen bombing
in the pacific ocean and at the same
time another giant kaiju species was
discovered and this one was named
anguirus
and was later said to be a rival species
of the g-man
in this appearance godzilla got into a
daily fight with a quadruped monster
and eventually killed him but now
godzilla has to again fight the jsdf
and the humans were in disarray none of
their weapons could hurt the g-man
and they even dropped bombs but nothing
happened at all however godzilla was
outsmarted and buried in an avalanche
caused by
missile fire by the jsdf fighters number
three
king kong vs godzilla 1962
so it seems that godzilla wasn't as
invincible as we all thought he was
anyway in 1962 godzilla gets released
from an
iceberg which was formed from the
avalanche that trapped him back in 1955.
in this flick he was pitched against a
supercharged king kong who was
surprisingly
getting more powerful after being fed
with a ton of electricity by the jsdf
they both battled and godzilla almost
won the fight but a lightning strike
revived an almost
dead king kong and revitalized the ape
to continue part 2 of the fight
which ended in both of them falling into
the ocean so while kong came back to the
shore
godzilla disappeared and retreated so
this would be counted as another defeat
number 4 mothra vs godzilla in 1964
although in the 2019 king of the most
this movie mothra and godzilla
was shown as a symbiotic pair of super
species
this wasn't the case with the original
meeting of these two kaiju
mothra vs godzilla of 1964 marks the
first crossover between these two
great monsters one of mothra's ex was
discovered off the show of japan but at
the same time godzilla emerges
and begins rampaging across japan making
his way straight for the egg
this resulted in mothras showing up and
battling the g-man but ended up being
killed by him
however two of mothra's larva a hatch
from the egg and used a silk spray
to cocoon godzilla and sinking him back
into the ocean
number five return of godzilla 1984
in this 1984 flick a new godzilla
emerges from the volcano and begins his
regular exercise of destruction
so in this a soviet submarine was
destroyed in the pacific
and they believed it was done by the
americans and diplomatic
crisis ensues which threatened to
escalate into nuclear war
the japanese intervened and revealed
that godzilla was behind the attacks
in this movie the soviets tried to nuke
the g-man but was foiled by the
americans
japan however developed the super x and
armored flying fortress
the super x battle godzilla but was
destroyed later on
however a homing device lured godzilla
back into a volcano
and a subsequent explosion trapped him
inside it
number six godzilla and mothra battle
for earth 1992.
in middle 1992 following the events of
godzilla vs king ghidorah
a meteorite crashes off the ogasawara
trench and awakens godzilla
in this movie another origin story for
mothra was created
and batra another flying kaiju was
introduced
so in it the earth created batra to
counter an ancient civilization which
changed the ecosystem and the climate
which later became uncontrollable so
mothra awoke and fought an apocalyptic
battle with batra
who lost the fight in the movie these
two fought each other again but was
violently interrupted by godzilla and
they then joined forces to defeat the
g-man
although batra was killed by an atomic
breath mothra managed to
pick up godzilla and dump him back into
the ocean
number 7 godzilla 1998 in this movie an
iguana nest is exposed to the
radioactive fallout of a military
nuclear test in the french polynesian
islands
and decades later in the south pacific
ocean a japanese fishing vessel is
suddenly attacked by an enormous
creature which
after interrogation of the survivor the
name gojira
is mentioned intended to be a very more
realistic depiction of godzilla the 1998
design is a very drastic redesign
to the point of looking almost nothing
like the japanese counterpart
the cgi model's appearance and stan
seems to be based on the tyrannosaurus
rex
and he also didn't have the durability
of the japanese
monster after all he was killed by
air-to-ground missiles fired by jet
fighters
something that would rather be an itch
for other
godzillas number eight godzilla mothra
and king ghidorah gmk 2001
in this third incarnation of godzilla to
appear in the millennium series of films
he was a supernatural entity spawned by
the restless souls of those killed in
the pacific theater
during world war ii to combat the beast
the prophet
hirotoshi isayama awakened the three
guardian monsters of japan which were
baragon
mothra and king ghidorah in the hopes
that they would defend the country
all three monsters were defeated
including the jsdf but they did take
advantage of a weakness
and with a missile strike they tore the
neck of godzilla
but he survived the blast however when
he tried to fire his atomic breath it
instead exploded the g-man and
completely vaporized him
number nine godzilla against mecca
godzilla 2002
in yet another reboot of the godzilla
continuity godzilla against mecca
godzilla reintroduces mechagodzilla
for the millennium series here godzilla
attacks japan in 1999
and the japanese government dredges up
the bones of the original godzilla from
1954
and uses them to construct an
anti-godzilla weapon called
kiryu it was sent to combat godzilla by
the g-man's roar awakens godzilla's
spirit within the machine
causing kyrie to go berserk after
repairs it was sent back into battle
disabling godzilla's heat ray and
unleashing its absolute zero cannon
chasing the g-man away with a massive
chest injury
and thus winning the battle but with a
huge cause with kiryu being
non-functional after that
number 10 shin godzilla 2016. in shin
godzilla it is proposed that godzilla is
some kind of prehistoric sea creature
that found itself surrounded by nuclear
waste on the seafloor in the 1950s
and rapidly adapted to withstand it and
mutate so after coming ashore
the creature continued to evolve three
times until it became
shin gojira which was the third tallest
incarnation
so it battled the us and the japanese
military and was unaffected by any kind
of weaponry
even the biggest explosions fortunately
in the battle it expended all of its
energy and became
dormant therefore using this weakness a
plan was executed to make him do the
same again
and force feed him with a blood
coagulant that would freeze him
and put him in suspended animation thus
winning the battle
number 11 godzilla filius in planet of
the monsters 2017.
godzilla phillies was a version of
godzilla
20 000 years into the future and was
depicted as very hostile attacking
humanity on site
rather than waiting for it to be engaged
in battle
this godzilla broke off from the
original godzilla at some point into in
the 21st century
via cell division and ended up growing
into the same height of godzilla scene
in the beginning of the movie
in the film nothing could even touch the
g-man and after
finding a weakness the remnants of
humanity used emp
probes to disable godzilla's shield
which protected him from everything
and once they buried themselves into the
monster's body
the resulting chaos from the emp causes
godzilla failures to implode
and kill itself but even though he was
killed which was a defeat
the original godzilla awakes and that is
a different story altogether
and so with that we come to the end of
the list of all the times godzilla lost
his life
or was defeated in battle if you
disagree with this list then put your
thoughts in the comment section below
anyway do like share and subscribe for
more kaiju and monster
videos